Від телескопів до Великого адронного колайдера —
кожен новий науковий інструмент переосмислює питання,
які ми як науковці
та допитливі розуми можемо з розумом ставити.
Високопродуктивні обчислення, або HPC,
увійшли до цього елітного списку у 60-х. Сьогодні
квантові комп'ютери стукають у ті самі двері.
Ласкаво прошу! Мене звуть Іс Кондусіф де Коффі,
я інженер-програміст тут, в IBM Quantum.
У цьому курсі ми прагнемо навчити студентів
і фахівців тому, як квантові обчислення невдовзі
працюватимуть разом з HPC-інфраструктурами,
щоб забезпечувати обчислювальні можливості.
Ти дізнаєшся, як квантові
та класичні комп'ютери спілкуються та обмінюються даними,
як писати програми, що використовують обидва типи заліза,
і як ця інтеграція відкриває застосунки, які ми можемо вирішувати вже сьогодні.
Ти здобудеш практичний досвід роботи з реальним квантовим залізом
і класичними кластерами високопродуктивних обчислень,
запускаючи квантові задачі поряд з традиційними HPC-навантаженнями,
навчишся інтерпретувати результати впевнено
та визначати місця, де квантове прискорення
дійсно може допомогти з обчисленнями,
а де — ні. Понад усе ти зрозумієш,
куди рухається майбутнє комп'ютерів
і яким шляхом ми туди дістанемося. Ми вважаємо,
що цей курс є важливим
і своєчасним, і переконані,
що поєднання цих технологій буде необхідним
для досягнення обчислювальної переваги.
Це може мати широкий вплив у різних галузях,
зокрема в хімії, де це може уможливити
швидший дизайн ліків і дослідження матеріалів,
у фінансах —
для розумніших моделей ризику
та виявлення шахрайства, у штучному інтелекті та машинному навчанні —
для оптимізації моделей. У цьому курсі
ми детально розглянемо обчислювальні ресурси,
моделі програмування та квантові алгоритми.
Ласкаво просимо і зануримося!
Є що обговорити.